good morning guys
I am finishing breakfast and about to
head to the JK films office we're gonna
work a little bit more on that project I
talked about in the last vlog but before
I head to the office I just want to tell
you about a little story where I ended
up swallowing my own tooth big shout-out
to dr. Madani he is Tiff's dentist
actually she recommended me to go see
him because he's one of the top cosmetic
dentists around and I had a chipped
tooth long story short bark Joe and I
used to have sparring sessions in his
rifle overall learning kickboxing one
day we decided to go a little harder and
for me I was kind of lagging it in terms
of buying equipment because I didn't
know how serious I was gonna take it so
I was like I'll get gloves we'll do a
little like boxing maybe just pad work
or whatever an eventual is okay I'll get
the shin pads I'll bring a spark email
get some head gear and they realize how
important a mouth guard was we decide to
spar and we're going a little harder
this particular day and I get caught
with an uppercut like Joe oh and I get a
bite down and it shatters and then
doesn't shatter that would be nuts it
chips this front to theater and I can
feel like this powdery sensation in my
mouth right afterwards and I'm like
there's something in my mouth I don't
know what it is at first I thought it
was my fake too so I haven't thanked you
for here I just never had a tooth grow
back after I lost the baby tooth so they
basically built a bridge on the back of
my teeth to connect it and have a fake
tooth kind of placed there anyways I
thought that chipped off I get broke off
and it was in my mouth but I was we were
so into the whole thing and I don't want
to like be like oh you upward
me and like we got to stop so I kept
going as we continued though I end up
swallowing whatever was loose in my
mouth and it wasn't until after the
sparring session ended I was sitting
there I was feeling around my mouth
won't let you know what my face is feel
here so wasn't that I eventually
realized awesomeness and you chunk from
my front tooth and I was like oh crap I
swallow my own tooth always a part of it
and for me I'm the kind of guy that
never goes and fixes anything until I
have to have to fix it that eventually
came because for me I don't take care of
my teeth very well and that chipped my
tooth started getting discolored because
it was such a deep like cut into the
tooth and I guess when I brush it it
just never quite get inside there so
there's always a bit of it that's never
brush like yes so starting game
discoloured I drink a lot of coffee so
that never helps TIFF makes an
appointment to dr. Madan he's office I
get a deep cleaning because I hadn't
been to a dentist in five years which is
I know disgusting but it was five years
we had a deep cleaning and he took out
all the plaque all the disgusting stuff
I didn't realized I was built up in my
mouth kind of embarrassing and and
finally had the chip fixed so big shout
out to dr. Madani and everyone at his
office Japan my visit if you ever get
uppercut in the mouth and chipper tooth
he had to fix it alright so that was my
morning story session time to go to the
office
[Music]
today's meeting was about creating
something we've never did before an idea
is called a pitch deck and what that is
is like a summary of all the characters
and everything that's going to be in the
pilot episode and all that and we're
going to be sending that over to one of
my new friends who was an awesome
executive producer for me I think it's a
Asian case once in about eight minutes
well if it was Asian female Kings it
would be better yeah yeah from like from
an Asian standpoint and kind of knowing
how Hollywood's views like content and
what makes money the Asians are usually
not where the money is that now it is no
way out now yeah you think one is to
close it maybe once this stuff some
movie was able to change that to
understand that this is a town that
jumps on trends they they don't everyone
does want to get fired so they see
somebody get a sale and the crazier
chains just made a hundred north let's
do a sit-down yeah like a ninth-inning
that's how the towers it's all the
strands and like try and everyone's
chasing the last thing that our acting
class what we learned that right now
it's not a great time for white people
in general because most of the roles are
going to minorities exactly thank God
finally it's been like a hundred years
god damn it but the cool thing also is
right now if you're East Indian like
India Indian then it's a good time for
you because they're doing a lot of
auditions that's true it's a good time
Brown
and get time to be a woman in Holmen
fountain woman it's always been a pretty
good time to be a woman in Hollywood I
think we call but you have short careers
true cuz you're only hot for so little
time listen if you're watching this you
better stay hot Kasim anymore home
alright just finished I mean it's been a
long day just finished my meeting for
the show today from the production
meeting we also locked in some shoot
dates super excited about that she seems
like everything's kind of falling into
place and oh I started storyboarding to
midway through the meeting just because
I realized the timeline of everything is
happening really really fast now and
everyone's kind of coming all the
department heads right now are asking
hey Casey it was a director where the
storyboard said how do you want to shoot
it like how many shots are we gonna get
of this like you know what angles do you
want so I spent a little bit of time
today to start the storyboarding process
and oh man I'm rusty with that right now
just just drawing stick figures is
really really hard I'll keep you posted
on more stuff as we get as we line up
more things for the show anyway so now I
am headed back home to spend some
quality time with the family it's my
it's my happy hour you know I don't need
to go to a bar and get some drinks it's
gonna be you know at home laying out and
couch with the TV running some dinner
and that's my happy hour that's my happy
place I know it's actually really fun so
we've been playing every night for the
last three nights this is how we spend
our quality time now I know we've
replaced watching Spongebob because it's
been fun well recently we're now playing
Minecraft when my preferes cam out I
didn't understand what the craze was
about like I just didn't understand like
why are people playing on like such bad
graphics and like why what is going on
the world's going backwards with video
games and their recent
i sat down I was like I was just bored
like I finished all my editing I was
like yeah just you know spend some time
with Isaac he's really into Minecraft
and I just got so obsessed with mining
cobblestone cobblestone is the coal
that's in coal yes and when you find
coal it is so amazing and it's so like
rewarding and then now I've been
obsessed with fishing okay you're
obsessed with fishing yes chili creepers
for that dynamite see looking at scrap
cult members yes you're minecrafters who
were crafters in it and then what is the
number one thing not to do at nighttime
don't mine at night no no no no you know
it's so cute because I think when we
were playing like just a couple nights
ago we were playing all together what
was your big thing oh yeah I never
thought they'd vote through my parents
from be playing Minecraft or do you
think of us now
dang it's finally you guys are finally
playing video games giving our cool
points yeah yeah yeah real cool their
parents now that's good cuz we're like
right we're literally right on the
tightrope of not being cool like any
second now we're gonna fall off we're
gonna be the most lamest parents of the
world to him alright so we're playing
minecraft the first time has been so
well for you guys first time for you
there's my three days we played like two
nights so we're gonna play tic Vittel
yes it explained with tick belt and
table and pick rollers so excel is first
thing that with me which is like
basically move picks network Isaac and
Casey
where Isaac and a yeah Ziggy in the bill
I medieval that's her to become medieval
sounds a good role plays medieval times
Ville this is like a dream come true
hunt you've been wanting to make a
Minecraft video I have yeah alright we
go my Helen no you're a bother
why am I always the gun I was a girl
just now oh you got a cow right this is
our house
welcome to our crib MTV Cribs these are
our beds
the blue ones mind you kill ones
remembers time I get the brown one the
true color I like what you guys could
see my character the toys buddy staring
me back guitars yeah whose idea was to
put the flowerpots on top you don't
think we're gonna bump her head wake up
oh yeah Gracie yeah check out the garden
that Isaac
flowers yeah and then we have a melon I
created it wunderbar - I got some boots
like no I want to collect more leather
when I get a whole outfit well I made
you a tunic I know you lost it yeah I
remember I was like the latest fashion
yeah you throw an egg yeah watch out man
I'm gonna hit it I'm a head of chicken
with it oh yes I made iron golem I did
it
what does that mean okay shot these are
the body part yeah he's our bodyguard
noise what if I have our own bodyguard
really do anybody get angry
yep you won't what do you think of my
man cave you read my eggs what's up with
people standing in my boats man wait
don't kill I don't watch screwed guys
my weapon oh there you go my axe Bugs
Bunny wait you're gonna come my
bodyguard
dude he is fired where is he he's these
men laid hands on us apprehend them at
once
Oh party guards so dumb fighting each
other like our bodyguard doesn't know
how to deal with the one sitting in the
boat oh my goodness I die oh my gosh
what happened oh I don't know
yes thank you be born boats how come
they're not coming out they're scaredy
cats
Oh our bodyguard can't swim either he
doesn't like dealing with the water I
did all the fighting all right you and I
gotta have a little talk man when people
lay hands on us you do something about
it that's what you do that's what you're
hired for that's what drew me like a
burst eyes again the right oh you guys
true games I mean I guess it's no use
[Music]
my eyes are burning we cut all right
that is good night wait that means you
guys get more like bad omen her I wonder
if vegan players I better stay away from
eating cow feet and meat stuff in this
game that's funny because I humanized
the cow sometimes I I do feel bad why
don't I kill them immediately what about
the little baby calf I don't know um
really I I see I see a mom cow and a
baby cow and I'm like I do kill them
once just to be like as it's a video
game and I actually did feel better
brush mine didn't go did I put that why
are we humanizing digital no I mean well
do they use particle scientists that
didn't experiment with a robot like they
had to turn off the robot and you were
an indie program the robot to cry and
say no please don't kill me no and then
people are like not to make some cow
skin clothing if I can humanize digital
cows looking this way no like
I try to let his fashion from Caicedo
top it drop him thank you
try it on com2 my boots looking very
stylish look it's hairpiece you're like
yeah girl rocket
I'll go look around the grid go ahead Oh
Oh give me a creepy look give me a dog
like I'm a fashion designer in this
world I am off to find more leather no
but look at me look like alright why did
you get in the lava shot me when you
said look at me nothing started being in
the love and I thought you intentionally
go in the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right thank you for watching
how was it making a gameplay video
minecraft my dream come true is like
your YouTube dreams you could grab your
baby boy
that's right because he's your number
one fan my embarrassing you know
[Laughter]
alright I know
[Music]
[Music]